こんにちは、こんばんは！
- こんにちは！
- おはようございますでしょうか　こちらバンクーバーは「こんばんは」ですけども、
- おはようございます！
- 今日はね　日本語でマクシーさんと
ドイツ語についてお話しようと思います
- どうぞよろしくお願いします
- えー　マクシーさん、　　どうぞよろしく
じゃあ　まず自己紹介をお願いします
- マクシーと申します　日本に住んでいます
日本語は１２年前から勉強してて、
今は日本人にドイツ語を教える仕事をしています
- 面白いですね　僕は日本に行くとき、よく本屋さんに行くんですよね
本屋さんに行くと、やはり始めに言語、「language」のセクションに行きます
でそこの七割の本は英語　英語の勉強用
あとは　中国語、韓国語、スペイン語、
ドイツ語のセクションはそんなに無いんですよね
- 少し（笑）
- どうですか　なんの為に、その主な動機って言うかね、
主な原因はなんでしょうか　日本人がドイツ語を勉強する主なモチベーションはなんでしょうか
- えっとね、あのー
女性の方だと、クラシック音楽が好きな人
- なるほどね
- でそういった方とかは
例えば　シューベルトとかバッハとかベートーヴェンの歌詞を
ドイツ語で歌えるようになりたい　という人が多くて
音楽の街のウイーンに行ったりとか、
ベートーヴェンが生まれた土地　ボンに行きたかったりとか
という方が多いんですけど、他にはドイツの哲学
に興味がある方もいますし、
あと若い人だとドイツに留学してみたい、経済学でドイツで働いてみたいとかいう人もいます
- あのー　ドイツのロック音楽とかはどうですか　マンハイムとか
マンハイム？　なんだっけ　ロックはあまり知らないけども
よく聞きます　そういう動機でドイツ語を勉強する人もいるんですよ
- ああ、
そうですね　ハードロックとか好きな人も結構日本でもいます
そうですね
- なるほど、　はい
あのー　ドイツはね、　僕にとってはドイツ語っていうかドイツっていうか
ドイツと　まあ、あの　オーストリアでしょ
その中央ヨーロッパの、西ヨーロッパとか　非常に大切な国、大切な文化
ですよね　それは僕は知ってます　それも魅力的ですけど、
日本に住んでて島国でしょ？
よく英語を勉強をする　まあ最近は隣の国の中国語とか韓国語もありますけども
やはり遠い、　ドイツ語の勉強をするのは偉いですよね
- 　そうですよね
- そして難しいでしょ　英語に比べて　そうでもないですか
- えっとね、面白いのは　昔日本のお医者さんは全員ドイツ語の勉強をしていました
今は大学で英語なんですけど、日本の大学で
英語の次にドイツ語を勉強する学生さんが
昔と比べて減っていますが、今でも多くいまして
で　お医者さんだと　例えばカルテとか
専門用語がドイツ語だったりします
で今は英語に変わってきているんですけど　昔は全部ドイツ語
だったので　日本で例えば病院に行くと、先生とかも「私も大学で習いました」とか言います
- なるほどね　じゃあ日本語とドイツ語を比較しますとね
ドイツ語では　もういわゆる男性、女性、中立性とかあるでしょ
そして　なんですか　ケースエンディングとか　色々複雑でしょ
日本語の場合はその複数形も無いしジェンダーも無いし
非常にそういう意味では　僕いつも思うんですけど　日本語のほうが許すわけですよ
- そうですよね　うん
- 何を言ってもまあなんとか
いけるわけですよ　日本語の場合は　しかしドイツ語はそうじゃないんでしょ　もっと厳しいんですよ　どう思いますか
- でも私は日本語は始めに耳から覚えて話せるようになったので　例えば「わ」とか
そのあたりも　後で書き言葉ですごくガチャガチャなったことはありました
最初に文法やってなかったので　後から勉強して良くなったんですけど、　ドイツ語の場合は
最初からセットで覚えたほうが良いと思います
多くの方に　「die der das 」女性男性中性名詞のルールを先に覚えたいという人もいるんですけど
ルールを覚えるんじゃなくて、　毎回単語を勉強するたびに
セットで共に覚えたほうが失敗率は下がります
勉強する時に　「これはdie」みたいに毎回男性名詞と共に勉強すると
むしろルールだけ勉強すると難しいと思います
- そうですね　そういう習慣をね
この言葉にはこれ、これが習慣的になってくると、あまり複雑に考えないで
自然的に　　でも「die der das」 だけじゃ無いでしょ
色々あるけれども
いやーしかし　　僕がドイツ語を勉強した時　今でもそんなによくできませんけども
ドイツによく仕事で行った時に
やはり　まあその時のドイツ語は悪くなかったけど　今は悪くなってるけれども
やはり　「der den dem des」 一生懸命勉強しようとした時には
何も進歩しなかったんです　ただ聴くだけ、読むだけ、
話だけする、　心配しないでも、何も起こらないから心配しても
そういう気持ちになった時に、やっと僕のドイツ語が少し進歩してきた
- 本当にそうだと思います　心配するということ、そのドキドキ感があると、あんまり
上達しない　話せる勇気がまず必要だと思って
- そうですね
- だから　自分でドイツ人の友達一人でいいから　自分に興味を持っている人
一人見つけて、　そうすると自分に興味があるからこそ　下手なドイツ語でも
話そうと思えば話を聞いてくれるので
うん　そう　まず仲間を作ること　それが大事
- そうですね　まあ　僕も
個人的には知らないけども、ツイッターで日本人がね　グルージア（Georgia）
カフカス山脈の国でしょ　グルージアね　彼はこの言葉を勉強しているわけですよ
で当然　日本人がグルージアにいるなら現地の人が一生懸命　彼がグルージア語で話そうと思えば皆応援するわけでしょ
だけどもドイツは違うんですよ
ドイツは　おそらく日本人がドイツに行ったら
もし非常に流暢でないドイツ語で話しかけた時に、ドイツ人は英語で答えてくるじゃないですか
- なんかでもそれって日本人でもそうなんですよ
私の見た目だと日本で歩いたらどっちかというと日本語で「こんにちは」って挨拶されるより「Hello！」な感じに　子供とか
全員そうなんですけど、　相手に「私はドイツ語を勉強しているのでドイツ語で話しかけて下さい」って言えば
変えてくれます　ドイツ人は外国人にとって英語のほうが簡単だと思いこんで　英語で話しかけているだけであって、
でもね　多くの日本人に　特にドイツに留学している日本人は
「私そんなに英語出来ないからドイツ語でお願いします」って言う人もいます
- ああ、それはいいね
英語が流暢であってもそういう答えが良いわけですよ
「すみません、あまり英語出来ないから」
- あと　ベルリンとか都会に行けば行くほど英語が出来るドイツ人がたくさんいるんですけど
おすすめするのは　都会じゃなくて田舎に行ったほうが本当にドイツ語しか通じない所とかいっぱいあるので
留学とか初めてドイツに行くなら、　都会に行くより田舎のほうが風景も綺麗なんで
- そうなんですよね　綺麗ですよね　ドイツのちっちゃな街、田舎の街
それこそ中世期の　そのままの姿、　ローゼンハイムとか
Dinkelsbühl　とか　僕は色んなそんな街に訪ねましてね
泊まって　安いし　本当に楽しいです
まあ　色んな意味でドイツは楽しいと思いますよ
- 楽しいです
- ある人はドイツは重い、厳しい、とか
まあそういう人はどこにでもいるけど　僕にはドイツは楽しい所
だからぜひ　皆さんドイツ語勉強して下さい
- 勉強して下さい！
- マクシーさんのリンクをディスクリプションに載せますから
- この下をクリックして
- ぜひクリックしてね
マクシーさんのチャンネルに行って、ドイツ語を勉強して下さい
じゃあ、今日はここまで　どうもありがとう
- バイバ～イ！